en esta ocasión tengo curiosidad por
saber cuánto tendrá que acelerar el
piloto de este avión para despegar de un
portaaviones busque algunas estadísticas
en internet y esta es la imagen de un
avión f-18 hornet lo escribimos f-18
hornet
y tiene una velocidad de despegue
velocidad de despegue
de 260 kilómetros por hora y ya que
estamos hablando de velocidad que es un
vector vamos a suponer que la dirección
de la velocidad es esta de la pista del
port avión y cuando tengamos alguna
cantidad positiva vamos a suponer que el
sentido es el de esta pista esos aviones
cuando despegan de un portaaviones no
solo usan sus motores para imprimir
velocidad aquí hay un pequeño riel que
los engancha y los jala como si fuera
una catapulta o una resortera
incrementando su aceleración la longitud
de esta pista es de 80 metros
aquí me pregunta es cuánto tiempo tarda
en despegar y cuál es la aceleración
necesaria que deberá tener este avión al
momento del despegue
anotemos nuestros datos nuestra
velocidad final es de 260 kilómetros por
hora
nuestra velocidad inicial va a ser cero
y antes de continuar con los cálculos
quiero asegurarme de trabajar con las
unidades correctas ya que la longitud de
la pista está en metros y aquí mi
velocidad está en kilómetros quiero
transformar la velocidad en metros por
segundo así que lo que quiero es
transformar esto 260 kilómetros por hora
y como quiero quitar las horas
tengo que multiplicar esto por algo que
tenga horas en el numerador y segundos
en el denominador qué cantidad va a ser
esta pues esta cantidad será en una hora
cuántos segundos hay sabemos que una
hora tiene 60 minutos y cada minuto
tiene 60 segundos 60 por 60 son 3600 y
voy a aprovechar este mismo cálculo para
también quitar los kilómetros de acá
quiero dejarlo como metros por segundo
así que para esto tengo que
multiplicarlo por algo que tenga
kilómetros en el denominador y metros en
el numerador que es lo que va a hacer
esta multiplicación pues va a ser en un
kilómetro cuántos metros hay
que hay mil metros en un kilómetro y
ahora sí tenemos todo para poder hacer
este análisis dimensional aqui quito los
kilómetros de aquí con los de acá las
horas también se van y me quedan las
unidades que estoy buscando metros por
segundo
recuerden siempre que hagan un análisis
dimensional verificar que estas
cantidades tengan sentido si voy a 260
kilómetros por hora voy a recorrer
muchos menos kilómetros cada segundo
pues el segundo es una cantidad de
tiempo mucho más pequeña y por eso es
que lo dividimos entre 3.600 si recorro
cierta cantidad de kilómetros en una
hora entonces tendré muchos más metros
en esa misma cantidad de tiempo ya que
los kilómetros tienen muchos metros mil
metros para ser exactos y por eso es que
lo multiplicamos por 1000 entonces esto
nos va a quedar que es igual a 260 por
1000 entre 3.600 y
y sacamos nuestra calculadora y
escribimos 260 por 1000 igual entre
3.600 y nos queda que es 72 puntos 22
222 pero vamos a redondear lo a 72
metros por segundo y esta es mi
velocidad final ahora si continuamos con
el problema sabemos que la pista mide 80
metros y vamos a suponer que hay una
aceleración constante cual deberá ser
dicha aceleración nosotros hemos visto
en vídeos anteriores que el
desplazamiento el vector desplazamiento
es igual a la velocidad promedio por el
cambio en el tiempo y como estamos
hablando de aceleración constante
podemos decir que esta parte de nuestra
velocidad promedio va a ser el promedio
de la velocidad inicial y la velocidad
final esto va a ser igual a la velocidad
final más velocidad inicial entre 2
y cuál va a ser nuestro cambio en el
tiempo cuál va a ser esta parte si
pensamos en ello veremos que esto es el
cambio de velocidad dividido entre la
aceleración si lo queremos ver con
números vamos a tener que la aceleración
que también es un vector es igual al
cambio en la velocidad entre el cambio
en el tiempo
y como nos interesa el cambio en el
tiempo vamos a despejarlo y para esto
voy a multiplicar ambos lados de esta
igualdad por el cambio en el tiempo
entre la aceleración como estoy
multiplicando a ambos lados por lo mismo
no la estoy afectando pero me va a
ayudar a simplificar así tengo el cambio
en el tiempo entre la aceleración por la
aceleración igual al cambio en la
velocidad entre el tiempo por el cambio
en el tiempo entre la aceleración si
hago esto puedo quitar este cambio del
tiempo de aquí y de acá y quitar la
aceleración de manera que me queda que
el cambio en el tiempo es igual al
cambio en la velocidad entre la
aceleración y que es el cambio en la
velocidad pues es la diferencia que hay
entre nuestra velocidad final y nuestra
velocidad inicial sustituimos hasta una
fórmula y nos queda que el cambio del
tiempo es igual es igual a la velocidad
final menos la velocidad inicial y todo
esto se divide entre la aceleración y
esto lo podemos sustituir en nuestra
fórmula conocemos ya todos estos datos
el cambio en el tiempo es la velocidad
final menos la veloz
inicial / la aceleración y ahora pues
vamos a simplificar esto como estamos
multiplicando fracciones vamos a
multiplicar numerador con numerador y
denominador común denominador velocidad
final más velocidad inicial por
velocidad final menos velocidad inicial
y todo esto entre dos por aceleración
esta estructura de la fórmula quizá les
sea familiar de lo que hayan visto en
sus clases de álgebra podemos hacer la
multiplicación de estos binomios pero
para que este vídeo no sea tan largo voy
a escribir directamente el resultado sin
hacer el desarrollo de la multiplicación
tal cual eso lo pueden hacer ustedes por
su cuenta eso nos queda que es la
velocidad final al cuadrado
menos la velocidad inicial al cuadrado
todo esto entre dos veces la aceleración
y como ven pudimos deducir la fórmula
del desplazamiento sin tener que haberla
memorizado usando solo la velocidad
final y la velocidad inicial y la
aceleración y aquí conocemos todos los
términos excepto la aceleración por
ejemplo conocemos el desplazamiento que
es de 80 metros conocemos la velocidad
final que es de 72 metros por segundo y
conocemos la velocidad inicial que es de
0 y ahora usamos esta información para
encontrar nuestra aceleración ustedes
pueden encontrar esta fórmula del
desplazamiento o la distancia cuando es
la versión escalar aquí lo que estamos
viendo son vectores la dirección va en
el sentido de la pista de despegue pero
estamos trabajando solo con las
cantidades para simplificar los cálculos
algunas veces van a encontrar esta
fórmula como 2 por la aceleración por el
desplazamiento
igual a la velocidad final al cuadrado
menos la velocidad inicial al cuadrado
cuando se trata de la versión escalar
queda como 2 por aceleración por
distancia igual a velocidad final al
cuadrado menos velocidad inicial al
cuadrado parecería algo misterioso pero
no lo es pues nosotros acabamos de
deducir la usando esta fórmula del
desplazamiento igual a la velocidad
promedio por el cambio en el tiempo y
nos quedó esta bonita fórmula que de
hecho vamos a usar para calcular nuestra
aceleración y también para saber lo que
experimenta el piloto con dicha
aceleración en el portaaviones ponemos
la información que conocemos esto es
igual a 2 por la aceleración por el
desplazamiento el desplazamiento es de
80 metros y eso es igual a la velocidad
final al cuadrado que quedamos que es la
velocidad de despegue 72 metros por
segundo al cuadrado menos la velocidad
inicial que es ser cero al cuadrado
sigue siendo cero así que de hecho esto
lo podemos quitar
despejemos la aceleración voy a dividir
ambos lados de esta igualdad entre 2 x
80 metros la aceleración me va a quedar
que es igual a 72 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
entre 2 x 80 metros
esto nos queda que es igual a 72 entre 2
por 8 16 160 y ahora las unidades van a
quedar de esta manera aquí tenemos
metros al cuadrado por segundo al
cuadrado entre metros pero esta parte de
las unidades es igual a aquí escribimos
72 entre 160 a 72 al cuadrado que no se
nos olvide el cuadrado 72 al cuadrado
entre 160 y las unidades son metros al
cuadrado
entre segundo al cuadrado
por por el recíproco de esta unidad que
está dividiendo la multiplicamos por uno
entre metros este metro se va con este
metro al cuadrado y me queda la unidad
metros por segundo al cuadrado que es
correcta esa es la unidad de la
aceleración ahora hagamos nuestros
cálculos sacamos nuestra calculadora y
nos queda 72 al cuadrado entre 160 el
resultado es de 32.4 que podemos
redondear a 33 más o menos 33 metros por
segundo al cuadrado nuestra aceleración
es igual a 33 metros por segundo al
cuadrado muy bien para tener una idea de
la cantidad de aceleración que es esto
si nos dejáramos caer libremente desde
un edificio o un precipicio dejáramos
caer nos la gravedad de la tierra nos
aceleraría a 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y la aceleración que
encontramos es
33 metros por segundo al cuadrado es
casi el triple de la aceleración de la
gravedad otra forma de verlo es que la
fuerza aunque aún no hablamos de la
fuerza lo veremos en vídeos próximos la
fuerza que siente este piloto es mayor
es mayor a 3 veces la fuerza de gravedad
estoy experimentando una fuerza tres
veces mayor que la gravedad 3g son
aproximadamente 30 metros por segundo al
cuadrado una analogía sobre cómo se
sentiría esto es imaginarse al piloto
voy a dibujarlo aquí arriba pueden
imaginarse al piloto de aquí que está
sentado manejando el avión aquí estás o
su asiento y lo que él siente cuando
este avión está acelerando hacia acá él
va a sentir una opresión acá y acá
y acá todo su cuerpo estaría sintiendo
una opresión qué tan grande es esta
opresión bueno ustedes pueden imaginarse
a este piloto que se encuentra acostado
en el suelo y con esta aceleración el
piloto se sentiría que pesa tres veces
más de lo que pesa realmente imagínense
si ustedes fueran los que estuvieran
acostados aquí en el suelo la opresión
se sentiría como si tuvieran a otras dos
personas encima de ustedes
ese tipo de presión es la que siente
este piloto cuando está alcanzando esta
aceleración para llegar a la velocidad
de despegue lo que para mí es una idea
muy interesante finalmente lo último que
nos preguntan es cuánto tiempo tarda en
alcanzar esta velocidad de despegue con
esta aceleración que encontramos bueno
lo podemos calcular mentalmente tenemos
que la aceleración es igual a 33 metros
por segundo cada segundo así que en el
primer segundo tendremos 33 metros por
segundo
durante el segundo segundo alcanzaremos
66 metros por segundo casi los 72 así
que nos va a tomar un poquito más de dos
segundos alcanzar esta velocidad de
despegue de 72 metros por segundo si
queremos encontrar la cantidad exacta lo
que hacemos es sacamos la calculadora y
dividimos la velocidad de despegue 72
entre la aceleración que es de 33 y nos
da que es igual a 2.18 1818 que podemos
dejarlo en 2.18 así que el tiempo que
tarda en alcanzar esta velocidad de
despegue con esta aceleración es
2 puntos 18 segundos